hello everyone so we'll continue with
our discussions on the topic of shear
Center specifically in today's lecture
we will look at a direct application of
the theory that we had developed in the
previous lecture so in that previous
lecture we had mentioned and emphasized
very clearly that the theory that that
we were developing had to do or was
restricted for thin walled open sections
so if we take a quick look back at the
diagram that we had drawn earlier so
this was the kind of structural member
that we were looking at so in fact this
was our starting point so we had a
cantilever beam which was shaped like
this the two most important
characteristics of this shape are that
it is open-ended so these two ends are
not joined and very importantly the
thickness of this structural member is
very very thin
when I say thin it basically means that
it is thin in comparison to the other
dimensions of this beam okay so the
application that we are going to look at
will be at a very specific variant of
this kind of a thin walled open section
and if you remember we had mentioned
that the motivation for taking up this
kind of a generic figure here was was
basically to to to capture the in a very
general way the important kinds of
shapes which are commonly used in
engineering practice for example an
l-shaped beam or a Channel's shape beam
so
also an eye shape beam or a t-shaped
beam z-shaped beam but in addition to
those shapes we can also have a beam
which has an almost circular
cross-section what I mean by an almost
circular cross-section is that instead
of a complete circle it will be
open-ended like this but instead of a
general shape like this it will be a so
this this R could be part of a of an
actual circle so that is the example
that we would be taking up today
okay so this is the shape we are
interested in this is the shape of the
cross-section
if you important points to note this arc
here is part of an actual circle
furthermore this thickness is very small
compared to the average radius of this
circular shape and what we are
interested in doing here is to find out
the location of this shear Center okay
now now we know that the location of the
shear Center is a purely geometric
entity meaning that it is completely
independent from the kind of loading
that this beam is is imposed to so it
might it might occur to us that for the
purpose of finding out the shear Center
we really do not have to bother about
the loading of the the loading that is
imposed on the beam and that is true we
really we really should not be worried
about any kind of loading because as
long as we are absolutely sure about a
very specific cross section we can be
sure of the way of finding out the shear
Center but that is that notion has to do
with the for the mathematical theory
behind this behind the shear Center but
in order to have a proper physical
understanding of the situation
especially as it pertains to the
concepts of the generation of the
torsional moments as applied by the
external load and as balanced by the
distribution of shear stresses which we
had time and again discussed in our
previous lecture it is it is perhaps
more useful and informative if you
actually consider an external load a
specific case of an external load and
then try to find out the
shir centered with regards to that but i
again emphasize that ultimately whatever
the answer will get for the sheer center
it is not going to depend on the load
handle and we'll see that okay so what
we do first of all is to set up our
coordinate axis now the moment we see
such kind of a very regular shape what I
mean by regular is that it has some sort
of natural symmetry to it it is our
motivation to somehow orient our axis
aligned with those axis of symmetry so
for example this in this particular
shape has a natural axis of symmetry
here so along this horizontal axis
passing through the center and our
natural our natural first temptation
would be to set up our coordinate axis
perhaps at the center of this of this
circular shape and maybe orient one of
the axis along the horizontal axis of
symmetry okay suppose we do that
suppose we set up our axis like this so
suppose let's say that our centre is
somewhere here and we set up our y axis
and the z axis like this okay
I want to have a clear cut discussion
about this because in most of the
textbooks you will see where they are
solving problems this discussion is not
really exposed in an explicit fashion so
I'd like to have a clear-cut discussion
about this you see if you remember what
we had discussed in the in the previous
lectures we had mentioned that when we
wanted to find out the location of the
shear centre our first job was to find
out the
distribution of the shear stresses on a
particular exposed section induced by a
cut and as we develop the theory now if
we take a quick look back at that we saw
here that this shear stress it
ultimately or maybe if we go back on
mode slide
so here
we saw that this shear stress got
expressed in terms of the bending stress
which was the Sigma xx now we had
mentioned during the development of the
theory that when we were finding this
expression of Sigma xx in the previous
lectures on unsymmetrical bending
basically so when we were using when we
derived this thing this was this formula
was derived first of all starting with
the y and z axis in such a fashion that
they were centroidal axis that is the y
in the z axis passed through the
centroid of the cross-section under
consideration so if we have to use this
formula then we must set up our y and z
axis at the centroid and this entire
derivation of the shear centre location
was done keeping in mind that ok so what
are we doing here you see here we have
we have put our y and z axis at the
center of this circular shape however
you note that the center here will not
be the centroid of this particular
section because a part here is missing
had this not been missing this would
have been a perfectly symmetric annular
cross-section in which case the centroid
would have been at the centroid at the
center of this circular cross section I
repeat myself if these two ends were
actually joined so that the entire shape
or the entire cross section here was in
the form of an annular circle then in
that case surely this centre would have
been also the centroid of the cross
section but in this case this part is
missing which means that the centroid
will actually be shifted a little bit to
the left
you can even without any computation you
can
you can understand that because this
part the counterpart here which is
missing it will kind of kind of pull the
location of the centroid here but
because of the of the symmetry about
this horizontal axis it will still be
along along this z axis so actually the
centroid would be a little bit to the
left of this Center so ideally we should
be referring to the axis which are not
this y and z axis rather which are let
me use a different color to denote that
rather we should be denoting this thing
by something like this
okay
but I do not wish to delete the
red-colored y&z axis for a certain
reason which will be clear now in a few
minutes so to resolve this confusion
about the axis what I'll do is I'll
first of all write down the expression
of the shear stress distribution refer
to the blue-colored y and z axis such
that the origin is actually located at
the centroid of the of this particular
cross section so let me make this clear
that this thing is the centroid so if I
write down the expression for the shear
stress I can just look back at the
previous at the previous lecture notes
and you see this is the one that I'm
interested in so this is this is the
entire expression and you note that it
does include this externally applied
transverse load P so we just write this
down
so
Sigma X s is equal to Sigma s X is equal
to minus P divided by I Y Z square minus
I Y I said x in the numerator we have iy
you said - I've I said qy where we again
remind ourselves that qz is the first
moment of area about the z axis and qy
is the first moment of area about the y
axis now is it possible for us to have a
bit of a simplification on this formula
you note that as I had already mentioned
this particular cross section it has an
axis of symmetry which is this
horizontal axis so whether you take the
red-colored z axis or the blue-colored z
axis they are coincident and the axis of
symmetry is along those axis now if we
have an axis of symmetry then you can
immediately conclude that the value of I
y Z will be equal to 0 so iy said is the
second moment of area we know that I
wise that expression is like integration
over the entire area y y times Z times D
so because for every element which is
above the z axis there will be a certain
value of y and there'll be a counterpart
element below the z axis which would be
having a location denoted by minus y so
when we integrate over the entire area
that it will it will result in a Y Z
being equal to 0 so you understand
that the the way that we have located
our coordinate axis this blue colored
coordinate axis it it so happens that
the y and the z axis are also the
principal axis so we write that down
here
because of the choice of Firaxis iy z is
equal to zero therefore our Sigma X s is
equal to Sigma s X is going to be equal
to P divided by I Y I said where I have
cancelled the minus that is present here
with the minus that will be present here
this iy said being 0 iy q said and here
this I wise it is 0 and you note that
again this iy cancels with this iy so so
overall what we have is just p qz / i
said all right now you note that
whatever we have done till now has been
with reference to this blue colored
coordinate axis this this y axis and
this z axis but ultimately as a result
of the inherent symmetry of the cross
section about the horizontal axis what
we are ending up with is the expression
of the shear stress which involves the
external load but it involves only the
first moment of area about the z axis
and the second moment of area also about
the z axis so we do not have anything in
this expression which is with reference
to the y axis so if we come back to this
diagram and see that for a moment you
imagine that instead of this z axis
perhaps you were actually referring to
this to this red coloured z axis then
would that make any difference to the
resulting value here i repeat whatever
we have done till now for this Sigma s X
or Sigma X s
we have ended up with this expression
and it involves only things which are
with reference to the z axis but suppose
you say that no I am referring the
things with referee with reference to
this red colored z-axis not the blue
colored z-axis then would it make any
difference to the resulting value here
the answer is no it will not make any
difference because of course Y is
different if we consider the red axis or
the one or the blue axis but the but the
z axis is absolutely the same in both
the systems so whether you take the blue
system blue colored reference axis or
the red colored reference axis the the
quantities which are calculated with
reference to the z axis they are the
same why am I making such a big deal of
this this very niche point you see
ultimately we have to find out the
torsional moment the torsional moment of
the shear stresses which should be
distributed over this thin member now it
is much easier to find out the torsional
moment of the shear stresses which are
distributed here about this axis which
is passing through the centre instead of
this one I repeat when I ultimately find
out the distribution of shear stress and
I want to compute finally the torsional
moment due to those shear stresses about
an axis about a longitudinal axis it is
far more convenient for me to have the
longitudinal axis which is passing
through this point this actual centre of
the circular shape rather than this one
which is a little bit eccentric because
you see the distance of all these of all
these points which are lying here they
are the same from this because this is
the center of this circular shape so
fortunately as a result of this formula
like this which depends only on the z
axis I can move back from this blue
colored access to this red
access and it will not make any
difference okay so even though we have
used the expression for the Sigma xx as
derived based on the on the on the
centroidal axis but just fortunately as
a result of this thing we can move back
to a pair of our two to an axis which is
which is not which is not the centroidal
axis okay
so to go ahead with the solution of
finding the location of the shear Center
I will take some very neat and clean
steps so the first step would be to find
out this value of qz for this section
second we would be finding out the value
of this high z now please note even
though I had been referring to this qz
as the first moment of area we have to
we have to understand that this is
actually like the first moment of area
so I said is is like a global property
for this entire cross-section so I said
is calculate for the entire cross
section is the second moment of area of
the end across section but this qz it's
like a local property so every point
where you sit here when you sit here at
different points of this member the
value of the qz is going to be different
so it's like the first moment of area
that is present over this and this thing
will be absolutely clear when we
actually compute it so the first two
things that we'll do
to find the
location of the
sheer centered so first thing is to find
you said
all along the cross-section second is
fine I said for the whole cross-section
after we have done these two steps what
we'll need to do is come back to the
expression of Sigma X s is equal to
Sigma s X because we already know the
value of Q and Z from the qz and I said
from the previous two steps we can find
out the expression for Sigma X s this
the shear stress and because the Q Z
would be calculated for different points
all along the cross-section the
expression of Sigma X s would also be
dependent on the location that we are
looking at over the entire cross section
which means effectively what we would be
getting is a distribution of Sigma XS
along the cross section so after we do
that what we'll need to do is
so let's write this as the distribution
after that
torsional movement contribution
and balance
so what do I mean by this again
referring back to our previous lectures
the shear stress distribution that we
obtained in the previous step that will
enable us to find out the the
contribution to the torsional moment
over the entire cross section due to
that distribution and next what we'll be
doing is to balance that torsional
moment contribution from the shear
stress to the torsional moment
contribution from the externally applied
load P and that will give us the
location of the shear Center so let us
proceed to find out the location of the
shear Center by following these steps
one by one so first of all we are going
to find out the Q Z all along the cross
section okay
so let's let's draw the cross-section
quickly once again
this time I look at my my z-axis like
this
I understand that my y-axis will be like
this and this IM ffice eyes is no longer
the centroid this is not the centroid
but rather it is the center of the of
the circle of the circular shape now we
perhaps easier if I to understand if I
just extend this a little bit more so
this is just for the purpose of clarity
okay
No
because we are talking about a very
specific cross-section we have to
mention clearly what is the what are the
extents of these two ends so these those
extents would be represented by
by this angle alpha and as I have
mentioned repeatedly earlier the same
angle alpha will be subtended by the end
of the cross-section which is below the
z axis so the angle that this end will
make here that is also going to be alpha
so let me make that clear
so this angle is also going to be alpha
now I am interested for the purpose of
finding the qz all along the
cross-section at different points along
the cross-section so I want to sit at
different points here here here all
along this cross-section and I want to
find out the value of the qz okay so how
do I do that if you if you remember what
we have done near the end of the
previous lecture and we can quickly
refer to that also so it should be
somewhere here okay so you focus your
attention here this Q Z was basically
this thing integration 0 to s Y TDS you
note that the TDS represents the
elemental area but we are doing the
integration from 0 to the particular
location s so the 0 represents one end
of the open of the open cross-section
and this s represented a generic
location anywhere within the
cross-section so let's repeat that and
calculate it in the context of this
specific cross-section
so qz will be equal to let's just write
down the formula why tds i again
emphasize here that as we had discussed
in the previous lectures also this t is
having the same value all along the
cross section it is possible to have a
theory where this is perhaps varying but
that is just an extra complication
without much return of investment as far
as the physical understanding is
concerned so we'll just stick to the
simpler case of a constant thickness all
along the cross section okay so how do
we translate or how do we compute this
particular thing for for our for our
cross section here so what we'll do here
is we'll take this generic distance s
from this open end so we'll start from
here we understand that s equal to 0 is
present here and we are going to move
along this so what we can do is just
mark it out in this fashion
so this is s equal to 0 and this is s
equal to s so we are basically looking
at a generic bit of the cross-section
which is like this so you understand
that as I move along the cross section
like this the area that will be covered
will keep on increasing until I reach
here where it will be the maximum okay
now what about the Y part so you
understand that when I'm when I am
sitting at this at this zone sure enough
if you if you zoom into that the
different points so so if I if I just
draw a little zoomed in view of this
thing it will be like this
and you understand that the different
points which would be lying along the
thickness would very strictly speaking
have different distances from the z-axis
so these different points would be
having different Y values y coordinate
values from the z axis but again you
remember that this thickness is very
very small that's the key point to
remember here this thickness is very
very small so for all practical intents
and purposes the little variation of the
Y values for these points will really
not matter and what we'll do is we'll
take some sort of an average distance
from the z axis so this Y that is
present here we are not going to
strictly adhere or we are not going to
strictly talk about different points
rather we will talk about some some
average point or some point which which
represents a typical point within this
thickness so surface if we say that the
the average radius of this of this
section is capital R so what we mean by
that is let's say that
so if this is given by our we are only
going to look at points which should be
located along this arc which would be
passing somewhere along the middle of
this very thin cross section so this Y
would be for that for a point which
would be lying on this on this blue arc
instead of anywhere else on this
thickness so now it becomes quite easy
to write what we can do is this s you
understand is like this so our s is
going like that and you understand that
it will be easier to do the whole
calculation if we just if we just make
use of the angles here so let's say that
let's say that we that we represent the
the angle here by a generic angle by Phi
so s will be equal to R times Phi
what we'll do here is we will denote
we'll denote this entire angle that
entire angle Wi-Fi so you understand
that the expression that I have written
here for as s equal to R times Phi
should actually be R times Phi minus
alpha okay but as far as the D s is
concerned it doesn't make any difference
this little difference of alpha here
because the Alpha is a constant for this
particular cross section so it will be R
times define the D S will be R times D
Phi you also note that the distance Y
will be represented in terms of these
geometrical parameters the capital R and
the Phi as R sine Phi so for any generic
point the y will be R times sine Phi
so just in case if that is not clear you
note that we have our arc like this and
this entire angle is Phi this distance
is R and this is our Y so this is
there's the little bit that we're
concerned here so I've just isolated
this bit here and just to have it clear
that y is equal to R sine Phi okay so
now you're ready to to calculate this so
integration R sine Phi times T times D s
so D s is our D Phi and now you note
that when we go from for for the limits
of s going from zero to s the
corresponding limits for Phi would be
alpha to a generic Phi so okay we have
to be extra careful to note that Phi
does not start from zero because the
zero for the Phi is on this horizontal
axis we are not interested in any point
there we want to start from this point
which is s equal to zero so s equal to 0
corresponds to Phi equal to alpha so you
can understand this clearly from here if
s equal to 0 Phi should be equal to
alpha so that's what we have used here
and any generic point is equal to s that
is just Phi so no problem there so the
upper limit is no problem okay so this
thing will be equal to so we have our
square going outside because that's a
constant doesn't depend on Phi the t can
also go outside the integration that
doesn't depend on Phi so what we are
left with is integration from alpha to
Phi
sine Phi D Phi and that is nothing but R
squared t minus cos Phi we have to put
the proper limits here so this like this
and the expression for qz turns out to
be cos alpha r square t cos alpha minus
cos phi okay because this phi here this
phi here represents a generic point here
that is why this qz is actually
representing so the value of this Q's it
is varying as we move the Phi from alpha
to this thing here so you know so you
can quickly understand that the value of
Phi here will be twice pi minus alpha
okay and this upper limit for five will
be necessary for us to calculate the
expression for ice Z and again I
emphasize that in sharp distinction from
this Q Z the value of the eysie which
we'll be finding out next will be for
the entire cross section okay so let's
do that
so next job is to find out find I said
for the cross-section okay so the
expression for eyes II is equal to
integration over the entire area Y
square da is the second moment of area
about the z axis so which is why Y is
involved okay now
for our cross section what we can do is
to is to translate this this generic
formula in terms of the R and the Phi
and the T just like as we had done in
the case of qz so this Y will be exactly
like before where we had written it as R
sine Phi and the DA if we
if you just take a look at the previous
diagram the DA will be for a generic
little element here so perhaps it will
be it'll be good if we if we draw this
diagram once more to have a better
understanding
okay so let's do that quickly
we can set up our axis passing through
the center and not the centroid so this
is our y axis and the z axis unlike the
previous case we are interested in only
an elemental area so we set it up like
this a little area here so the distance
Y will be again this distance so that
can be set up as R sine Phi no problem
there but what about this little area da
this area da what will be that so that
will be nothing but
T times D s so maybe to be useful to
just write it down separately here the
DA will be equal to T times D s you
understand that this here is my D s and
I want to express this in terms of the R
and the Phi and if you just quickly
refer to our previous slide here the D s
is the DSS Rd Phi so this is T times our
define you again note that the Phi is
calculated from this from this
horizontal axis okay
so why will be our sign Phi because we
have a square they put the square here
and for the DA will be putting T times
our D Phi now what will be the limits of
integration so we have to put the limits
of integration for Phi and you note that
in order to cover this entire
cross-section from here
starting from here which is Phi equal to
alpha as we go around and come here it
will be Phi is equal to alpha 2 Phi
equal to twice PI minus alpha so just to
make this clear again this angle here is
alpha and this angle here is alpha and
because this entire angle is twice PI so
the Phi will go from alpha to twice pi
minus alpha
okay so let's do this very quickly
so the r-cube will come outside we'll
have tea also coming outside and we'll
have this thing so that'll be sine
square Phi D Phi now we can quickly
convert this to an easily integrable
form in this fashion
okay I'll not go through the steps
anymore I just put down the answer here
which is
half our cutie
- I spy - twice alpha this radically
comes from the integration of this one
here and the cost to five will give me a
sign - five / - of course and that will
ultimately lead to nice simplification
and will give me plus sign to alpha
okay
I have this for my eyes II so let's take
an account of what we have achieved till
now as far as the steps required to find
out the location of the shear centre is
concerned so going back to the previous
page we see here that we have already
we've already done this step find Q Z
all along the cross section we have also
just fine
found out the value of isay now we can
immediately go to this expression here
for Sigma s X or Sigma X s and put down
the values of Q Z and is't that we have
found out and get the distribution for
the Sigma s X or Sigma X s so that's
what we are going to do
okay so let's go to that next slide the
next page
okay so you'll find out the distribution
for the shear stress and let's refer to
the to the formula once again okay so we
have here Sigma X s is equal to Sigma s
X is equal to p qz / I said think I've
made a small mistake here there is a
team missing in the denominator so we
should have a t here sorry about that
actually I missed it here also there
should be a t here in the denominator
but no problem we have corrected this at
the proper time okay so this is p qz / t
i said
so if we put down the values of qz and I
said what we would obtain is is P times
R squared t cos alpha minus cos Phi
divided by T and the expression for I
said was half R cubed
T
twice pi minus twice alpha plus sine two
alpha
okay so overall what we'll end up with
is just this the T from the numerator
will cancel will obtain P cos alpha
minus cos PI divided by maybe you can
take the two outs
upstairs in the numerator and this will
be R cube sorry this will be the just
the R times T twice PI minus twice alpha
plus sine twice alpha okay so now that
we have found out the distribution of
Sigma XS we are ready to determine the
the torsion and the contribution that
this shared this that this shear stress
distribution will have towards the
torsional moment and in turn how that
will balance the torsional moment due to
the external applied transverse load now
before we can do that it is extremely
important as far as the physical
understanding of the problem is
concerned to realize where this shear
stress distribution is actually lying we
had discussed this in the previous class
while we were developing the general
theory but will be again useful to
discuss this very quickly
so let's actually draw the beam
[Music]
let's say we have the beam here and
today we are considering a circular
cross-section an open-ended thin walled
circular cross-section and let's say
that this beam is fixed to a wall like
this and let's say that we have applied
some kind of a Tosh a and a transverse
load here so this is a very generic
representation of the transverse load we
really don't know where it is but we do
understand that this is being applied
through the correct location of the
shear centre so so if this is the line
of action here we we are we are
guaranteed to have the shear centre
somewhere on this line of action now as
we had discussed during our general
theory last time for the purpose of
carrying out the torsional movement
balance what we do is to take a cut
section on this beam
so that a cross section like this is so
a cross section like this
is exposed
what we had also done last time was to
name the the piece which was in front of
this cutting plane so this piece this
entire piece starting from here to here
so so this entire piece lying in front
of this cutting plane as as our piece
one and the one that is to its back as
to subsequently what we had done was to
consider this piece in isolation
so in isolation like this where we
understand this is just the piece one
where also the the externally applied
load is like this now we understand that
the shear stress distribution that we
are talking about is on this is on this
hatched edge on this hatched face so
this is the face which is at the back of
the cut piece one flush with the cutting
plane that is present here so I repeat
myself the shear stress distribution
that that we are concerned with and
which will contribute towards the
torsional moment which in turn is going
to balance the torsional moment due to
the due to this externally applied force
that shear stress distribution basically
this shear stress distribution which you
have just found is on this please note
that if we were to draw the the section
the cut piece to there would be an
analogous shear stress distribution but
whose orientation would be exactly
opposite to the shear stress
distribution orientation which should be
present here so so what do I mean by
that so let's say that so this this this
picture would be cleared if if we draw
this looking into the x axis so you
understand that the x axis is oriented
like this so if we look into the x axis
towards this negative direction the the
picture that we'll see there that will
help us to have a very clear-cut
explicit physical understanding so first
what I will do is draw that front view
looking into the x-axis for the cut
piece one so we go to the next page and
this is the
this is the diagram that we are seeing
now as I had drawn earlier
let me depict the externally applied
load like this so this is my P now you
please note that we are looking we are
talking about the cut piece one here the
face that we are seeing here this face
this is the front face okay so this is
the front face this front face is a free
face it will not have any shear stress
distribution on it but there is also a
back face there's also a back face which
is superimposed behind this or or rather
the front face is superimposed on the
back face there so if we want to draw
the shear stress distribution along it
what will it look look like now is it
going to
so
is it going to be oriented like this
where the arrows go in a clockwise
fashion or is it going to be in an
anti-clockwise fashion please note again
that this shear shear stress
distribution is shown on the back face
of
of the cut piece one that is the face
flush
with
cutting plane and in front of it
so is this the correct orientation of
the of the shear stress now the answer
is yes this is the correct orientation
because you see only if we have such an
orientation of the shear stress
distribution that it will effectively
contribute to a shear force which would
be like this and only if we have such a
shear force distribution that the the
force equilibrium of the cut piece one
will be will be balanced so so if you
just look back at the previous thing and
can I draw my shear stress distribution
like this only in that particular case
where the shear stress distribution on
the back face of this cut piece 1 is
oriented in a clockwise fashion that it
will contribute to a shear force on that
back face which would be oriented upward
and which would be balancing this red
colored externally applied transverse
force because you understand that it is
not enough for static equilibrium to
have the torsional moment balanced it is
also it'll also be necessary to have the
the force equilibrium true so as far as
the force equilibrium along the Y
Direction is concerned we must have a
shear force to balance out this
externally applied load and it is only
through a shear stress distribution
orientation in this clockwise fashion
that such an upward pointing fate shear
force will be present but what about the
cut piece too so for the cut piece too
if we go to the next page let us draw
the front view looking into the x-axis
for this cut piece to
you understand that this is my cut piece
too and this face that I'm looking at
this is the front face of the cut piece
to which is flush with the cutting plane
and behind it so if we just take a look
at the previous diagram I'm looking at
this piece too and I'm looking at this
front piece front face here okay so what
will be the orientation of this shear
stress distribution you see this face
here is is touching the back face of
this cut piece one the front field I
repeat the front face of this cut piece
too is touching the back face of this
cut piece one so the shear stress
distribution there will be exactly the
same but oriented in the opposite sense
so it will be anti-clockwise
and only if we have that the shear force
here will be like this and you you all
know very well that that if we if we
have such a situation
so this is this is my cut piece - and
this is my cut piece one
then if I have a shear force acting like
this here which is balancing this
externally applied so this is then on
this face I must have a shear force
which is opposite but equal in magnitude
to this and this shear force the the
downward pointing shear force this is
this shear Force which will be cont
which will be actually as a resultant of
the contributions from this shear stress
distribution so it is extremely
important to understand this the the
reason that I am emphasizing this and
spending such a lot of time on this is
that in many many textbooks in almost
all the textbooks that I have seen what
they show is that so it's a very
confusing kind of diagram what they show
is that the transverse load acting
downward like this and the shear stress
distribution that this show is this kind
of an anti-clockwise shear stress
distribution so which cut piece are we
talking about how is that kind of a
shear stress distribution balancing this
thing that is not clear I'm not saying
that it is what is shown in the
textbooks is wrong but it is kind of
very confusing so I thought that I make
this point very explicit and very clear
so I hope you guys understand this so so
with this physical understanding we can
immediately go to the next page and do
the torsional moment balance okay so
so this is my cut piece one my
transverse load is like this and
and the shear stress distribution is
like this now the axis about which I
about which I wish to take my my
torsional moment is this x-axis
axis about which
the torsional moment would be taken
okay so first of all we take the
torsional moment of of the beat so this
is our P here we understand that it is
passing through the shear Center so
if we understand that this distance is e
from the x axis so the torsional moment
due to P will be simply P times e and
that should be equal to the torsional
moment contribution from the shear
stress distributions so how can you
write the shear stress distribution
contribution so Sigma X s times the area
of an L so when you say an area it's an
elemental area and that's like a da and
we have already seen that the da is
nothing but t Rd Phi so the our D Phi
this is the elemental area and since we
wish to take so this is like an
elemental force so this is so this part
is like the da that multiplied with the
shear stress that gives us the elemental
force and we have to take the moment the
torsional moment of this about this axis
and you see what is the distance of of
any of these little elemental forces
that will be present at any point of
this cross section so if you just extend
the x-axis backwards it will be here
so about the x-axis the the moment arm
would be nothing but capital R so this
entire thing has to be calculated going
from one end to the other end so this
will be the limits of five will be from
alpha to twice pi minus alpha okay so
all that you have to do is substitute
the expression of Sigma xx that we had
obtained earlier so this this big
expression that we had found out for the
Sigma axis we have to substitute it
there and carry out the integration so
so if we do that what we end up with is
I will not go through the through the to
the to the intricate steps here and I
trust everyone will be able to do this
you see there will be no problem with
the with the denominator that's that's
just basically a constant little which
will come out of the integration what
will be left inside the integration will
be basically the contribution which
comes originally from the qz so so
that'll that will be just the cos alpha
minus the COS theta term and if we just
do it patiently ultimately we will
arrive at this expression so this is
twice pi twice P R
times twice pi minus twice alpha cos
alpha plus two sine alpha /
twice PI twice pi minus twice alpha plus
sine twice alpha now you see the
beautiful thing that has happened on the
left hand side we have the speed and on
the right hand side also we have the P
so as we had mentioned earlier
ultimately even though we are we are we
are making our calculations with
reference to a particular transverse
load like this but ultimately the answer
that we are getting for the location of
our shear Center which is this distance
Y from the x axis it is purely
independent of the of the P so what we
have finally is this thing this p
cancels and this p cancels so this is
our answer so this e is denoting the
distance of the shear centre point from
the x axis now one may one may think
that what we have basically obtained is
the distance of the line of action of
this force P from the x axis but we
really don't we have not really
explicitly calculated the location of
the shear centre that would be here sure
we know this distance in terms of all
the given way given parameters like
capital R and alpha but are we really
sure about where on this thing the shear
centre will be lying and yes we know
that by virtue of the nice symmetry of
the problem and that will be exactly
lying on on an axis which is parallel to
the z axis so the location of the shear
centre would be so let's let's mark that
out in white color so this will be
actually the location of the shear
centre
so II
is the distance parallel to z axis from
the x axis
the y-coordinate
for the shear Center
is
seed'um
okay so ultimately what we can say is
that the shear Center
we'll be located at z equal to e and y
equal to zero where the expression of E
is given by this huge expression thing
now as interesting exercises or as
further simplifications what you can try
to do is you can take different values
of alpha like you can have interesting
cases where alpha is equal to PI by 2 or
alpha tending to 0 and you can see what
values you obtain please note that alpha
tend that I mentioned that alpha tending
to 0 but not alpha equal to 0 so please
do not take alpha equal to 0 because
that would depict a a closed thin walled
section and our theory would not be
valid for that so it is really important
that we that we maintain our cross
section to be thin walled as well as
open-ended which is why you can make the
alpha as small as you want but you
cannot take that to be equal to 0 so
that a little slit has to be still open
at at the value of Phi equal to alpha
alpha being very small okay so that that
sums up our discussion regarding this
example problem and I hope some of the
more intricate concepts here would be
cleared through the very explicit
discussion that we have had so all right
thank you very much